this church in Cologne is protecting you
sir Asahina from deportation the Syrian
student must leave Germany because she
came to Europe via Italy German law
requires her to apply for asylum in
Italy user is on the deportation list I
hear that's all people that's go back to
Italy asleep in the streets so why if my
family live here why I don't have a
right to live with them the 24 year olds
asylum application has already been
rejected twice but this lutheran church
and its pastor are giving her temporary
protection for now she can be near her
father and brother who have been granted
asylum here in Germany the family was
torn apart by war her mother and
youngest brother are still in Syria
waiting for visas to Germany she keeps
her family together virtually with a
collage she made on her mobile phone
That's not me shootin the system makes
me so angry it's inhumane what state
what laws the right to place itself
above human rights in this fashion why
can't they forbid a family to reunite to
whom the church protects you sir but the
asylum offered by the church is not
official legal protection so far the
state tolerates this the police doesn't
raid Christian places of Prayer right
now about 600 refugees are being
harbored by German churches officials
have a problem with this the church
asylum can only be allowed to exist in
exceptional cases if clever lawyers
misused the original Greenland and
applied Church asylum to extend the
refugees day until deadlines expire then
we cannot accept this Larsson then
couldn't be at us at state start making
him for political reasons users father
left Syria three years ago he doesn't
want to talk about this as long as his
family still is in danger the situation
in Syria is not safe I mean everything
is changing from minute to minute from
hour to hour there is no country as the
original country above Syria I love my
my country and my stay
when she lived in Syria you sir had an
active life she worked with a UNICEF
project for war damaged children and was
writing her bachelor's thesis on
restoration of war-torn Palmyra now
she's stuck waiting in Germany for an
undetermined time period
[Music]
so I hope that we see my mother and her
brother soon and my statue is going
better as I dream user dreams of
completing her master's degree in
architecture in Germany one day she
wants to return to Syria and help
rebuild it after the war is finally over
you